[MUSIC PLAYING]
GRACE MOLLISON: My name's Grace.
I'm a Cloud Solutions
Architect based out
the London office just in case
there's any confusion where
I came from.
And I'm here to talk to you
about blending GCP security
controls.
When it comes to
security, they're
kind of tends to
be two approaches--
thinking about what your
users are allowed to do
and also what's permitted
within your organization,
and then also protecting
against threats and concerns
and the controls you need
to do approach there.
So as you would
expect with GCP, we
have a selection of controls.
And these are just a subset.
And this talk is all
about demystifying
how you can pick and choose
various controls to address
particular use cases starting
off with the first one, which
is what can your users do.
When it comes to
permissions, IAM
dictates what your users can do.
They dictate who can do
what on which resource.
But before I go in to talk to
you about how you implement
IAM in GCP, I need to talk to
you about the Cloud Resource
Manager.
The Cloud Resource
Manager allows
you to map your organization.
It's a hierarchical
organization,
so you can map your teams or
maybe how your applications are
configured to map to GCP.
In the context of
this talk, the thing
is it provides
hierarchical attachment
points for permissions
and organization policies.
OK.
So coming back to
IAM, when you use IAM,
you have to create
an IAM policy.
An IAM policy-- you bind
users to a set of permissions.
And the set of permissions
are called roles.
These are the users
that GCP recognizes,
but it doesn't preclude you
from bringing your own identity
along.
So you can use Active Directory.
You can use LDAP.
So once you've
defined your policy,
you then need to decide
where on the hierarchy
you need to attach it--
so whether at the organization
level, folder level--
the folders have a collection of
projects within them-- project,
or even at the resource
level themselves.
In GCP, as on-prem, you have
a number of privilege roles.
You know, like your
super user accounts.
So these are the ones that
you really, really need
to give least
privileges and restrict
the number of users who use
them, who are granted them.
So the policy admin
gives you that person
who has that broke
the ability to have
manager and policies all
throughout the organization.
The organization
role admin gives them
the ability to create
custom roles that apply
throughout your organization.
And Policy Admin folder
and project owner
are pretty self-evident.
So what you need
to do is you need
to think about what roles
your users actually have.
Are they central network
and security teams?
What permissions do they need?
Your data scientists, they
don't have the same permissions
as your central teams and
network security teams.
So you need to
think that through.
So when it comes to
thinking about all of those,
you need to then kind of take
a path to implement that.
Look at your
organization hierarchy.
Do that mapping.
Create that first.
Do the functional to IAM map.
OK.
So that's probably a
spreadsheet where you train,
OK, I know these
guys or these gals
need to be able to do that.
Then determine what you
need to attach that policy.
And you need to
audit all of this.
So this is going to be
an underlying theme,
the auditing and logging.
OK.
So let's just talk
through an example,
so you can understand
how this actually works.
So here we have a central
security and networking
team in this organization.
So they manage all the
network and security policies.
They've given teach team of
developers and developers
their own projects,
but they're not
allowed to make any changes
to the network and security
control.
They are allowed to
spin up instances.
So before I go on to
look at the IAM policies,
I just need to introduce
you to yet another control.
This is shared VPC.
This allows you to define an
RFC 1918 network, a network
network, which you can
divide up into subnets.
These subnets, the
service projects--
i.e. the projects that you've
given to your developers--
can then make use of.
OK?
So there are actually
three IAM policies
that you need for this
particular example.
They're are three,
because they're
attached to different levels
in the hierarchy and projects.
OK.
So I've just talked you
through some of these.
So the first one is attached
at the organization hierarchy
level.
This is for the network
and security admins.
So there's two groups
here-- the network admin,
so you've got managing
all the network controls
and the security teams that are
managing the security teams--
oh, the security roles, sorry.
OK.
And this is managed at the--
attached at the
organization level.
First of developer projects--
this is on the host project.
They need to be granted
network user, because they're
going to be using that
subnet that you're
going to give them access to
which is in the host project.
OK.
So they need to have network
user in the host project
as well.
Second one is that the
service project-- i.e.
the project that they spin
these instants up in--
they also need network
user there as well.
And they also need the ability
to spin up an instance admin.
OK?
So blending them all
together, visually you
can see where the
network and security
admins have access to manage the
shared VPC network in the host
project.
And you can see
where the developers
can use the subnets that's been
assigned to their projects.
Then they can manage the
instances in their project.
So looking at what you
can do, users can do,
there's Resource Manager to give
you the hierarchical attachment
points in central
management, Cloud
IAM for those
granulated permissions,
and shared VPC which allows
you to have the central network
and administration.
OK.
You'll see this slide a lot.
It's just kind of to
give you a reminder
of where they're coming from
in the logical groupings.
So at this point, I'd actually
like to introduce Charlie
from Verily, who's going
to explain to you how
they actually implement this
within their organization.
Thanks, Charlie.
CHARLIE AARONSON: Thank
you so much, Grace.
Hi, everyone.
Welcome.
I hope you have enjoyed your
time at GCP Next thus far.
My name is Charlie Aaronson, and
I'm a Technical Program Manager
working on Cloud Data
Security at Verily Life
Sciences, an Alphabet company.
As you heard from
Diane and Sundar
yesterday at
yesterday's keynote,
Google's mission is to organize
the world's information
and make it universally
accessible and useful.
Well, borne out of Alphabet's
Moonshot Factory, Google X,
Verily has the mission to
make the world's health
information useful,
so that people
can enjoy healthier lives.
As you might imagine,
working towards this mission
can often take a
number of forms.
And many times, we realized this
mission through partnerships.
For some of these
partnerships, such as Verb,
focusing on surgical
robotics, or on Duo,
where we work on evolving
diabetes management, GCP
and, indeed, G suite are at
the core of our collaboration
in terms of working together
as well as developing together.
In order to ensure that
we're set up for success when
using GCP both internally and,
indeed, for these partnerships,
we've developed and follow a few
key principles for cloud data
security and operations.
These are separability.
We need to ensure that there
is a clear differentiation
in between different project
teams and their data.
Maintainability--
thinking through how
our systems are going to
be used not just today,
but for years to come.
And three-- simplicity,
ensuring that we
create and advise the use
of understandable security
configurations.
And as you may imagine, bringing
these principles into action
often requires that we blend a
few different GCP and G Suite
tools and systems.
Over the next few
minutes, I'm going
to explain how we use GCP
hierarchy, G Suite Groups, as
well as Cloud Identity
and Access Management,
IAM, to accomplish and
meet our principles.
So let's start
with separability.
We need to ensure that
our surgical analytics
data is entirely separate from
our baseline biological sample
data.
We do this by organizing
our GCP hierarchy
into folders and then some
folders below that and project
below that.
That allows, as you
can see on screen,
for us to literally
separate out the data
and the subsequent access
ensuring that we adhere
to the separability principle.
Next comes maintainability.
We organize our
identities into groups
that are associated with
a specific role or project
within the organization.
So to give you a
tangible example,
think of Allison and Charlie,
who are both software
engineers on a given project.
They're contained
within a group.
And then the great
thing about this
is, if we have another software
engineer join the team,
we just add her to the
group, and she automatically
has all the access that
she needs to do a role.
It's a fantastic way
to ensure that we
maintain the level of groups
and access that we need.
Next, rather than adding
individuals to resources,
we add these groups to resources
via either a canned widely
available or custom role.
This allows us to focus on
ensuring that we get access
at the group level and make sure
that the appropriate people are
in the appropriate groups.
On a personal note,
this has saved me
an enormous amount of time in
troubleshooting access requests
and issues and is
fundamental to how
we approach maintainability.
Finally, comes simplicity.
By bringing together
these practices,
we work to create a consistent,
understandable, and, of course,
simple GCP access
control system at Verily.
We endeavor to use the
platform as intended
rather than rolling
our own solutions.
And we are thoughtful
about our hierarchy
and where we grant groups
access to resources
to ensure that we maintain, of
course, the appropriate access
as well as the
appropriate separation.
In using the
platform as intended,
we often find areas to
give feedback to GCP.
And this is fantastic.
Our relationship with GCP has
been really collaborative.
And this is not just because
we're an Alphabet Company.
This is because GCP is
all about collaboration.
So I encourage you all, go ahead
and use your account teams,
your support representatives,
or product form
to ensure that you
provide feedback
on how you're using the
product to make it better
for all of us.
Data security and
segmentation are
of absolute paramount
importance to Verily.
Thus, in order to ensure that
our teams and collaborations
are set up for success, we
have developed principles
which guide our deployment of
Google Cloud Platform, GCP,
at Verily.
I hope I've been able to share
some brief insights about how
GCP is helping us realize our
mission of making the world's
health information useful, so
that people can enjoy healthier
lives.
Thank you all so much.
And I'll pass you back to Grace.
GRACE MOLLISON: Thanks, Charlie.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
OK.
So continuing on
with the use cases--
number two.
Looking at enforcing,
what's not allowed?
There will often be
the case that you'll
want to have standard
controls that are spread down
throughout your org.
But you want to do
this without getting
in the way of your developers.
You still want them to be agile.
GCP has something called
organization policies.
So the organization
policy service,
it allows you to provide
standard controls that
provide enforcement
throughout your organization
that you can override
at different levels.
OK?
So I'm just going to keep it
simple and talk about colors.
But for every resource that
is supported by organization
policy, there's a
list of constraints
that tell you how that
resource can be restricted.
So in this case, we're
looking at a resource
that's got four colors.
You may recognize them.
And the standard
here is the fact
that you're only
going to have two
colors as the standard
colors that are
used within your organization.
So red and green,
this is your standard.
But as ever, there's
always exceptions.
So the first group says, well,
OK, we like the standard,
but we also want to use blue.
So you just add blue.
So you can augment it.
The other one says, well,
we don't want our team
to be able to use green.
Well, I quite like green myself.
So they can only use red.
And then the other
two, these standards
aren't actually applying at all.
So in this case, they've
got an organization policy
that they've defined
at the folder level
for the first one,
which is just yellow.
And the last group, they're not
having standards apply to them.
They can just use
whatever color they want.
So you can see how
you can be adaptable.
So you can set the
standard, but you can also
flex to meet the requirements.
OK.
So org policies and IAM
policies are orthogonal,
but slightly related.
So all policies are all
about how those resources can
be configured.
Whereas, IAM policy is about
who can access those resources--
OK, quite an
important distinction.
So moving on to look at how
you can protect your GCP
environment, think of maybe like
preventing data exfiltration.
Think of that as being the use
case as I walk through this.
That'll help, OK?
So as you'd expect, there is a
whole shopping list of controls
that you can use for
this particular use case.
I'm just going to talk
about some of the controls
I haven't already touched upon.
So let's start with subnets.
Subnets allow you to
define a logical division
in terms of traffic.
OK?
You can actually use
it to kind of separate,
you know, your database back
end from your application
middleware.
You can actually
have different teams
working at different subnets.
And you can use it--
when I say for HA
deployments, it's
that you can, obviously, have
subnets within different zones.
OK.
Firewall-- the
firewall, obviously,
helps you to manage traffic
between the subnets.
Because traffic, by
default, isn't actually
between the subnets unless
you specifically define it.
So the firewall is distributed.
It's up at the VPC network
that you define it.
It has, you know,
as you'd expect,
ingress and egress rules,
deny and allow rules.
One of the things that I
really, really like about it
is the fact that you can
have [INAUDIBLE] rules.
So just to understand that,
I'll just talk about firewalls
with looking at service
accounts to set up those rules.
So service accounts, so
one of the identities
I touched upon
briefly early on, it's
the programmatic identity
for your VM or application.
So using service accounts allows
you to set up firewall rules
in terms of intent.
i.e., rather than
thinking about, oh,
what's the IP address of my
web server or my database,
you can think I want to
allow my web server to talk
to my back end database.
It actually helps to
mitigate user error,
because it's just more natural
to think about it in that form.
So, you know, it's an
authenticated rules.
And, you know, obviously, I'm
excited, and I really like it.
OK.
So moving on, just want to
mention private Google access.
This enables you virtual
machines on your subnet
to reach Google API endpoints,
such as BigQuery, cloud
storage, via the Google
network, so you don't actually
have to go out to the
public IP address.
OK.
To supplement all
those network controls,
we had VPC service controls.
VPC service controls allow you
to provide a perimeter boundary
to complement those controls.
So it's defense in depth.
This isn't a replacement
for any of those.
It's there to help mitigate
data exfiltration risks,
like from misconfiguration
IAM policies.
Those things happen.
Maybe you've to make
sure that people
who are allowed to be
accessing your projects
are allow to access
those projects.
So I'll just go for
a quick example,
so you can visualize
what this actually means.
Here we have two projects
that are allowed to talk,
to communicate with each other.
So you've got the IAM controls.
You've got the firewall
rules out between them.
But as you can see, there
are other paths in and out.
You can have, you know,
an unauthorized client
might be able to get to the
data in your GCP service there.
It might look scary,
but we have something
to kind of alleviate that
pain, service access zones.
So here you can see that
you define this perimeter.
You define things like
from trusted IP arranges.
So if I talk you through the
unauthorized client, as if
[INAUDIBLE] imagine
that you've had
some sort of identity theft.
OK?
It's highly unlikely
that they are
going to be using that
identity to access
your protected project
from your network.
So it gives you a bit
of time to mitigate
the actual theft of the
identity in that way as well.
You can actually prevent--
using the zone, you can
actually define what
it's not allowed to talk to.
So you may decide
that these projects
you don't want them to be able
to write data to another cloud
storage bucket or to BigQuery
outside of those projects.
So it kind of keeps them
kind of covered up for you.
OK.
So blending those
together, you have
IAM for the granulated
permissions,
you have the set of
network controls,
and then you have
VPC service controls
to complement all of those.
OK.
So we've talked about what
your users are allowed to do.
Then let's talk about what
they're not allowed to do,
the unauthorized access.
You need to manage
who has access.
You need to
understand your users.
So have a central--
[INAUDIBLE] probably
the wrong word.
Have a central identity store
that you manage your identities
for.
So you can use Cloud Identity.
Or, you know, as I
said earlier, you
can use your own identity store.
Use groups, as Charlie just
walked you through earlier.
The OS login, this
allows you to tie
in who has SSH login to your
instances with Cloud Identity.
So you're managing
that centrally.
You give those users
the correct IAM policy.
They're allowed to
actually SSH in.
It's a central
administration, so you're not
worrying about actually setting
all that with random keys being
added to instances and metadata.
User IAM for least privilege.
Stackdriver--
Stackdriver is important,
because your logs,
your monitoring,
is the first sign of any issues.
So admin activity logs will
tell you who's doing what.
Who's made an access call
to a particular sources?
Who started up that VM?
Data access logs-- who's
had access to your data?
You can use Cloud
IAM to restrict who
can actually view those logs.
And then you can do
things like dashboards.
You can export them to
your own SIEM if you want.
You can filter.
And, obviously, you
can alert on that.
Service accounts--
service accounts
are the keys to your door.
So you need to manage
them properly, OK?
If you're running
on GCE, then we
manage the key rotation for you.
We manage the rotation.
You don't need to download them.
The blast radius is minimized.
We do understand that you
do need to download keys.
So even though I say avoid
downloading production keys,
I absolutely understand that
you might have applications
that are running
off-prem that you want
to access GCP API endpoints.
If you do that, you're going
to have to implement processes
to manage the downloaded keys.
Use things like various tools
to check that your keys aren't
upgraded to GitHub.
OK?
Restrict, put in policy--
so keys that expire quickly.
Minimize the radius
and the possibility.
Use the key management service
to encrypt your config files
and your service account keys.
Your service account
keys are secrets.
And then have a process
to unencrypt and use
them and gain audit usage.
So looking at that,
unauthorized access--
again, you've a
number of controls.
And this is just one
way of actually thinking
of dealing with this-- key
management service, Cloud
IAM, and Stackdriver logging.
OK.
So now, we talked about
managing and controlling
your GCP environment.
Now, let's think about
the fact, you know,
you're running an application
on GCP and how you protect that.
So let's think about a
web facing application--
so, again, another
set of controls
that you can use to
apply to this use case.
Starting off with
cloud load balancing,
GCP has a number of cloud
load balancing options.
But for our use
case, an application
exposed to the
internet, I'll just
focus on the global
HTTPS load balancer.
When you enable the
HTTPS load balancer,
Google infrastructure
mitigates and absorbs
many layer four
or below attacks,
such as SYN floods, IP fragment
floods, and port exhaustion, et
cetera.
It's generally
used in conjunction
with managed instance groups.
Managed instant
groups allowing you
to define a number
of identically
configured instances
that scale up and down.
So it can absorb any attacks
across those instances
if you so wish to.
OK?
In conjunction with global load
balancer, we have Cloud Armor.
OK.
And similarly to the
global load balancer--
that's a mouthful-- it's
distributed towards the edge
of Google's network.
So it can absorb attacks
closest to the source.
It's based on three main things.
It's built on three pillars--
policy framework, a rich rules
language, and the global
enforcement infrastructure.
It will help you defend
against DDoS attacks.
You can define
security policies.
You can do whitelists.
You can block traffic.
You can preview traffic.
It's a very powerful
tool that we've
made available to help you with
your web face and applications.
But it doesn't stop there.
OK.
Identity Aware Proxy, this has
evolved from Google BeyondCorp.
It allows users who have
got the right IAM policies.
It will authenticate and
authorize access to your web
facing applications.
I'm showing it here working with
Compute Engine and Kubernetes
Engine.
It works pretty much the
same with App Engine.
It's defense in depth
though, so don't
forget to set your
firewall rules up properly.
And don't forget to make
sure that you're mitigating
any unauthorized SSH access.
So we've talked about
your user authentication
and authorization.
The next thing you said
is what about your APIs.
So an API proxy, think
about it as an abstraction
above your API layer.
GCP has two types.
It has Cloud Endpoints,
which is great
if all your application
is all in on GCP.
It provides a management layer.
And it will authenticate
calls to the APIs.
If, however, you want more
enterprisey type features
and it's multi-platform,
then Apigee API Edge
will be the one that you
should be looking at.
So IAP is for your
users, and API proxies
for your authentication
of your APIs.
And your application code--
and you need to be secure,
and you need to trust it.
OK?
So-- user security
scanner for GCE and GAE.
Make sure you're mitigating
for the OWASP top ten.
Know your code.
So use private source repos.
Contain a registry
and contain a builder.
Know what's in your code
that you're deploying.
So from one end to
the other-- there's
the Identity Aware Proxy if
your users are accessing,
Cloud Armor in conjunction
with global load
balancer to mitigate,
help block traffic
and help mitigate
on DDoS attacks,
and then API proxies for
your APIs, all right?
So finally, and
not least, I just
want to talk about
watching what's going on.
So monitoring,
alerting, and enforcing.
So as you expect, we've got
a collection of tools again.
And as before, I'm just
going to talk about the ones
that I haven't
already spoke about.
So let's just have a quick
look at VPC flow logs.
There was a great talk
yesterday from Ines, the PM--
so if you didn't
catch it, then really
go and watch it on YouTube--
all about VPC flow logs.
They allow you to
get network telemetry
for to and from your VM whether
within GCP or whether it's
coming from the internet
going to your VMs.
It's useful for forensics
and security analysis.
You can export to an SIEM.
You can view this telemetry
data within Stackdriver.
So you can export
to any of the syncs
that Stackdriver supports, like
BigQuery and Cloud Storage.
Cloud Security
Command Center, this
gives you a single
pane of glass.
OK?
It gives you a picture, a
security slanted picture,
of your resources.
It's modular.
OK?
It gives you an asset
discovery and inventory.
What's really cool
about the inventory?
You know, you're
working in the cloud,
so you're going to be
scaling up and down.
You know, there might
have been some instances
in the past that have
been used to do, you know,
Bitcoin mining.
That's a big thing
at the moment.
Those were spun
up, then spun down.
You can still have insights into
those spun down or destroyed
instances.
OK, that's kind of a really nice
feature of the Cloud Security
Command Center.
It's got lots of
other nice features,
but that's the one that
I really, really love.
It integrates with the
data loss prevention API.
Data loss prevention API
allows you to classify
your sensitive data.
If you want more
information about that,
there is the showcase
where the DLP
engineers are hanging around.
Cloud Security Scanner--
to scan your applications.
It allows you to integrate
with third party tools as well.
And it gives you notifications.
So Forseti is one of those
tools it integrates with.
Forseti is open
source security tool.
And that's evolved from GCP's--
evolved from Google's
internal tooling.
It's community driven.
It's open source,
takes pull requests.
It gives you an inventory.
It allows you to
enforce firewall rules.
So if, for example, you
have a standard that
says this is the firewall
rules that I want to apply,
somebody sets it back.
Forseti will actually
reset that for you.
IAM Explain is
really kind of cool,
because it allows you
to understand the impact
of your IAM policies.
So the Forseti guys are
also around here as well.
So blending that together--
VPC flow logs for your network
telemetry, Cloud Security
Command Center for your single
pane of glass, Stackdriver
logging for who did what, where,
and when, and for the alerts.
OK.
So I'd now like to
introduce Arthur
from Verily, who's going
to talk to you about how
they watched what's going on.
Thanks, Arthur.
Thanks, Grace.
[APPLAUSE]
ARTHUR BRANT: Hi, everyone.
My name is Arthur.
And I'm a software engineer
at Verily Life Sciences.
I work closely with Charlie
building the services,
tooling, and scripting to keep
our health care data secure.
So my section of
the talk will be
diving into the weeds a
little bit on specific things
that we've done to
abide by best practices
to keep the data as
secure as possible.
So there will be
three big principles
that we speak about today.
One is how to generate,
persist, and reasonably analyze
your audit logs
to look at who is
accessing what data and
security configurations.
Two is looking at how
to reasonably perform
org-wide IAM policy reviews.
You need to know what's in
your policies to make sure
that they're secure.
And third is how you can
form company-wide roll outs
and patches in the event
that there is a security
vulnerability that
you've identified.
So we'll first
dive into logging.
In health care,
this is something
that we're legally required to
do for the most sensitive types
of data.
And it's generally
a best practice
that we should all be doing.
And there's some questions
that you may want to ask.
For example, for a particular
piece of sensitive data,
who all or what are
all of the identities
that access that piece of data?
Second, you may
want to look at who
is setting security
configurations
in your project in the
event that something
was opened up too widely?
And third is you may
want to due diligence
on a particular employee and
ask what are every piece of data
or every security configuration
update that, you know,
so and so has done
at your company.
Those are questions you may ask.
So there's three
big things that you
need to guarantee when using
Google Cloud Platform to make
sure that you can answer
these questions reliably.
Number one is you need to
turn on your audit logs.
By default, your security
configuration update
logs are on, but your
data read and data write
logs are not on for projects.
So it's imperative that you set
these on at the project level
IAM policy and that you also--
we'll talk about this
a little bit more
downstream, but-- that you check
that they're never flipped off
ephemerally.
Second is that you need
to export your logs.
Now, the natural
place that someone
may try to export the logs is
within the project for which
the logs are being generated.
However, we'll talk here
shortly on why that's
a very bad idea actually.
You may export your
logs through a couple
of different services on GCP.
GCS exports to JSON.
It's great for data robustness,
not the best for doing analysis
on your logs.
They also export
to BigQuery, which
is our preference and probably
the easiest place to really
dive into those logs.
And then if you need to
build some real time business
logic on top of
your audit logs, you
can also export
to Cloud Pub/Sub.
Now, the reason that I was
speaking of earlier on why
not to create a BigQuery set
in a project itself for which
the logs are going
to be dumped to
is because, oftentimes,
we set wide access rules
at the project level
IAM policy, and IAM
is fundamentally hierarchical.
So, for example, if you use
project editor, BigQuery
dataset editor, BigQuery
admin, storage object admin,
storage object
delete permissions,
you're going to be giving
a potentially wide group
of people access to
permanently delete your audit
logs with no means
of reproducing them.
And if you're in the
business of health care,
that's something that we
absolutely cannot have.
So instead, we've adopted
a different best practice,
which is to export logs
into a company-wide project
where no individual has
24/7 access to this project.
And we can ensure that
our logs are never
deleted by the teams for
which we want to be auditing.
Another key detail on this
slide is that you can see--
and Charlie spoke a little
bit more about this earlier--
we are pretty heavily
using cloud folders
to segregate different
clusters of projects
into different
hierarchical paths.
And this is very nice,
because now Cloud Folders
has a feature where
you can turn on audit
logging for all children.
So as long as the projects
are generating the logs
and the folder export is
configured appropriately,
you can have strong guarantees
that every single audit
log underneath some parent
label or parent folder
will be exported somewhere.
And for us, we actually have 1
to 1 parity between our cloud
folders and our
BigQuery datasets
in a company-wide super
privileged project.
And this will come
into handy later.
OK.
So the third principle
with audit logs
is that people need to
actually look at them
or you need to
run automated jobs
to check for specific things.
For example, who all has changed
your project level IAM policy
in the last month?
What individual
non-service accounts
have accessed data that should
never be accessed by humans?
And the way that we've
configured things
that you saw in
the last slide is
that, because
there's this 1 to 1
parity between a cloud folder
and a BigQuery dataset,
you can simply grant access
to whatever groups have break
glass access or super
admin access or TL
access on the cluster of
projects to their own audit
logs with BigQuery
Data Set Viewer,
so that they can read the
logs, and BigQuery job user,
so that they can actually
run queries against them.
This ensures that they
can look at their logs,
but also ensures that your
logs will never be deleted.
And you won't be liable
for that as a company.
OK.
Second big topic for
the day is looking
at how we can
perform IAM security
audits and some specific
use cases for that.
Going back to the
previous slide,
if we look at the
clusters of folders,
we can imagine that if a TL is
responsible for some cluster.
Whether it's the
data warehouse, you
know, the front end serving
app, the replicas in one folder,
they want to be able to
look at every single IAM
policy or some IAM
policy [INAUDIBLE]
for their set of projects.
Specific things you
may want to check
is that an identity outside
of your organization
does not have access to
sensitive information.
So, for example, if you're a
company that hires a consultant
and you decide to use that
consultant's @gmail.com address
and at some point
the deal is done
and you want to
remove their access,
this can actually be a
very complicated project.
You can't simply
delete the account,
because it may be
their personal Gmail.
So instead, you need to scrape
every policy recursively
and delete them.
And the only really way to
guarantee that is via this,
I think, the folder structure
and recursively crawling down
and updating the IAM policies.
Second big thing is you may want
to do routine audits to make
sure that only robot
identities have access
to some of the sensitive
data in your project--
so whitelists, specific
buckets, specific data sets,
specific SQL
instances, and ensure
that no one's granted
themselves access to look at it.
Third is, as we were
talking about earlier,
you have to make sure
that all of your projects
have audit logging on
and that this is never
turned off by a user.
So we should be auditing this.
And fourth, and this
is a problem that's
plagued pretty much all
of the cloud providers,
is that there is a
feature on GSC Buckets
and BigQuery data sets where you
can make the data within them
readable to the entire
world without requiring
any authorization.
It's great for global
research collaborations,
but you need to make sure
it's never on your most
sensitive projects.
So we, at Verily, have some
very robust tooling around this
to make sure that it
will never happen to us.
OK.
Third topic that we
want to talk about today
is how to perform company-wide
roll outs in cases
of time sensitive emergencies.
Again, the folder
structure is really
paramount to performing this.
So, for example,
one use case we had,
which is the first
one listed there,
was there were
three times in 2017
where we needed to patch
every single VM in the company
due to bugs, like the
global Spectre bug, which
are bugs that effect the OS
machines that Google doesn't
control for your VMs.
And to orchestrate
this smoothly,
the client is actually
responsible for rebooting
and patching every VM,
because Google is not
going to randomly turn
down your machines.
It could affect
production access.
So by having the
cloud folders, we
are able to look
at all the folders
that don't serve
production traffic,
immediately roll out a job to
reboot and patch their VMs,
and then go team by team for
ones that did serve production
traffic and, with the
consent of their TLs,
recursively reboot all
of their VMs for them.
And as a result, we
as a company were
able to reboot thousands of
VMs in a couple of hours.
Whereas, if you don't
have this structure,
it would be a nightmare
to even track down
the VMs in the first place.
Second case where this is
particularly useful is,
because we have a service
account with super admin
access at the top, we can
pretty easily add people in
as long as there's a couple
approvals to grant break glass
access to, for example,
security engineers that
find some mission critical
configuration issue
or other people on
a team in the event
that the TL forgot
to, you know, set up
the on-call group
appropriately, and we
need to give someone
access to the project.
And the third example here,
which we talked about earlier,
was being able to quickly
crawl your entire GCP universe
and remove a specific
identity from all access.
OK.
So at this point, I'd like
to hand it back to Grace.
And we spoke a little bit about
how Verily uses the best of GCP
to secure our
hypersensitive data.
Thank you, Grace.
GRACE MOLLISON:
Thank you, Arthur.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
Just to wrap up and
then for some Q&A--
so just a checklist.
You need to define.
When you start off thinking
about what controls you need,
define what your user
should be able to do.
Think about those controls,
the IAM map, functional map.
Think about what's not
allowed, organization policy.
And then think about what you're
trying to guard and protect
against.
OK.
What are the threats?
What are your concerns?
Choose your controls
from the shopping list.
Remember, these
are just a subset.
And I've just kind of put
them into a logical order.
Blend those controls together
for a defense and depth
approach, and monitor
all the things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]